se nos dice que estos dos triángulos
tenemos el triángulo pq r y el triángulo
abc son congruentes la longitud lateral
de cada cuadrado en la cuadrícula es una
unidad entonces cada uno de estos es una
unidad cual de las siguientes secuencias
de transformaciones mape al triángulo pq
r
en el otro triángulo tenemos cuatro
secuencias diferentes de
transformaciones así que por qué no
pausa este vídeo y descubres cuál de
estas mape al triángulo pq r
entonces este es pq r en abc y podría
ser más de una opción así que pausa este
vídeo e inténtalo muy bien ahora hagamos
esto juntos primero pensemos en la
secuencia y haré la secuencia en este
color púrpura recuerda que comenzamos
con el triángulo pq r entonces primero
dice una rotación de 90 grados sobre el
punto r primero hagamos esto y luego el
resto de la secuencia así que para girar
esto 90 grados una forma de pensar en
esto es que una recta como esa quedaría
así entonces r se quedará donde está
ya que es el punto sobre el que rotamos
pero p ahora va a estar justo aquí una
forma de pensar en esto es que para ir
de rr/ap bajamos 1 y 3 a la derecha y
ahora cuando haces la rotación vas a ir
1 a la derecha y luego a subir 3
entonces te va a estar aquí y puedes ver
esto
esta es la rotación ese lado se verá así
así que aquí está p y luego q va a estar
por aquí también va a rotar 90 grados
sobre r y así después de hacer la
rotación de 90 grados p q r se verá así
entonces esto es q así que hemos hecho
esta primera parte después una
traslación de 6 unidades a la izquierda
y 7 unidades hacia arriba entonces vamos
a mover cada uno de estos puntos 6
unidades a la izquierda y 7 hacia arriba
así que si tomamos el punto p 6 a la
izquierda 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 unidades hacia
arriba 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 lo colocamos aquí
así que ese es el punto p
si tomamos el punto r contamos 6
unidades a la izquierda 1 2 3 4 5 6 y 7
unidades hacia arriba 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 nos
lleva justo aquí y luego el punto q si
vamos 6 unidades a la izquierda 1 2 3 4
5 6 y 7 arriba es 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 queda
justo aquí entonces parece que la
secuencia funciona ap/ap qr en abc así
que funcionó la secuencia ahora
trabajemos la secuencia b haré esto en
un color diferente una traslación de 8
unidades a la izquierda y 3 hacia arriba
así que hagamos eso primero entonces si
tomamos el punto q y lo movemos 8 a la
izquierda y 3 arriba 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 3
arriba 1 2 3
entonces ésta será mi q roja por ahora y
ahora si muevo este punto r 1 2 3 4 5 6
8 y 3 arriba 123 entonces mi nueva r va
a estar aquí y por último pero no menos
importante el punto p 8 a la izquierda 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 y 3 arriba 1 2 3 queda
justo aquí así que esa traslación nos
llevará hasta aquí claramente todavía no
hemos terminado el mapeo aún hay más
transformaciones por hacer entonces se
ve algo así dice después una reflexión
sobre la recta horizontal que pasa por
el punto a entonces el punto a está
justo aquí la recta horizontal está así
entonces al hacer la reflexión el punto
a no cambiaría el punto r en este
momento está 3 unidades debajo de esta
recta horizontal así que estará 3 arriba
de esta recta horizontal por lo que el
punto r irá aquí sólo con esto podemos
ver que esta secuencia de
transformaciones no va a funcionar está
poniendo a r en el lugar equivocado así
que voy a descartar la secuencia de
secuencias e
permíteme hacer esto en otro color una
reflexión sobre la recta vertical que
pasa por el punto q así que vamos a
hacer eso la recta vertical que pasa por
el punto cu se ve así solo dibujaré esta
recta vertical entonces al reflejar lo q
se mantendrá en su lugar r está una
unidad a la derecha de la recta así que
al hacer la reflexión estará una unidad
a la izquierda y el punto p está cuatro
unidades a la derecha así que ahora
serán cuatro a la izquierda 1-2-3-4
entonces p estará aquí después de la
reflexión y así se verá después de esta
primera transformación esto se está
volviendo algo desordenado pero es lo
que probablemente tendrás que hacer tú
así que lo haré contigo muy bien
entonces hicimos esa primera parte la
reflexión y después una traslación de
cuatro unidades a la izquierda y luego
siete unidades hacia arriba entonces
cuatro a la izquierda y siete arriba
vamos a hacerlo cuatro a la izquierda 1
2 3 4 y 7 arriba 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 entonces q queda justo aquí
esto es sospechoso porque el punto queda
en el punto p de la secuencia que si
funciona así que no estoy seguro de esto
pero sigamos intentándolo entonces 4 a
la izquierda y 7 arriba 1 2 3 4 y 7
arriba 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 entonces se re
quedará en el mismo lugar que la
secuencia y luego el punto p 1 2 3 4 y 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 de hecho funciona esto
funciona porque este es en realidad un
triángulo isósceles pudimos mapear p q r
en abc con la secuencia c entonces me
gusta esta secuencia y luego por último
pero no menos importante intentemos la
secuencia de lo haré en negro para que
podamos verlo entonces primero hacemos
una traslación 8 unidades a la izquierda
y 3 arriba 8 a la izquierda y 3 arriba
comenzaremos aquí 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 y 3
arriba
1 2 3 aquí pondré mi q negra 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 y 3 arriba 1 2 3
pondré mi ere negra justo aquí en
realidad es exactamente lo que hicimos
en la secuencia de la primera vez
entonces te va a quedar justo aquí por
lo que después de la traslación de la
secuencia de llegamos aquí luego dice
después una rotación de menos 270 grados
sobre el punto a este es el punto a
menos 270 grados es negativo por lo que
irá en sentido horario digamos que si
tuviéramos que tomar esta recta justo
aquí si tuviéramos que llegar a 180
grados esta recta quedaría así y luego
si tuviera que recorrer otros 90 grados
parece que podría mapear lo aquí y esto
se ve bastante bien si tomamos esta
recta de aquí y rotamos menos 270 grados
se mapear a justo aquí y luego ese punto
r podemos decir que lo acompañará en el
viaje y quedará aquí también así que en
realidad me gusta la secuencia de
entonces todas las secuencias funcionan
excepto la secuencia b